speaking by the way of understanding
math I predicted this would happen and
it's happening we did a video a couple
months ago six weeks ago called you're
about to get slammed with the garbage
math and in that video I made the case
that after these massive declines in the
stock market in employment job loss
consumer spending all of the stuff
because of coronavirus at some point
from this insane bottom you would start
to see a recovery and percentage-wise
the recovery might look good so you
would start to see headlines like and we
have air travel up 120 percent oh my god
120 percent will hold on it was down 96
percent to only four percent of what it
was when it goes up 120 percent it's up
to 9 percent of what it was let's not go
crazy but this is the type of math that
they are going to use to trick you and I
said it's going to happen with stocks
it's going to happen with jobs and we
are seeing it last week headlines four
point eight million jobs created
remember we lost 46 million jobs 4.8
million came back Donald Trump went on a
national bragging tour about this is the
fastest and best job creation in the
history of the United States well hold
on a second first of all we got four
million jobs back after losing 46
million number two what did Trump do to
actually get those jobs back we would
have way more jobs back had we had a
competent federal response to
coronavirus rather than what we
experienced again bragging unemployment
rate down to 11 percent this is the
biggest one-month drop in unemployment
in history hold on a second we had
unemployment of 16 17 % real
unemployment arguably 20% you're
bragging now that we still have
historically high unemployment and they
are doing the full garbage math
treatment here's Donald Trump himself
just a few days ago the United States
economy added almost 5 million jobs in
the month of June shattering all
expectations
I was watching this morning and the
expectations were much lower than that
the stock market is doing extremely well
which means to me jobs what it means
jobs does the largest monthly jobs gain
in the history of our country the
unemployment rate fell by more than two
percentage points down to just about
eleven percent we're down to the eleven
percent number we started at a number
very much higher than that as you know
we broke the record last month and we
broke it again this month in an even
bigger way this news comes on top of
may's extraordinary jobs report the
largest job gain in history why well it
sounds like things are going pretty well
right oh wait a second we lost 46
million jobs before gaining 4.8 million
jobs now I think this is a good time to
remind you I want a good economy I don't
want any jobs lost in order to hurt
Donald Trump politically I don't want
any coronavirus cases or deaths to hurt
Donald Trump politically the reality is
of course employment is still well below
the pre-pandemic level we are obviously
still in a huge huge hole 15 million
fewer jobs in June than in February the
unemployment rate is down most recently
from fourteen point seven to eleven
point one at eleven point one it is
still higher than at any time since
World War two and again there's a
reporting error that continues to plague
these numbers the real number is twelve
point one the data from before this data
is from before the spikes that we've
seen in Arizona and Texas and others
Texas is sort of softening their opening
telling a lot of people that they should
stay home so let's see where things look
in another month or two if the pandemic
continues to explode and you know the
realistic expectation is we would see
slow improvement to the numbers as we
get closer to the end of 2020 and we are
in all likelihood going to start 2021 in
a significantly worse position than we
started 2020 that's the reality so do
not fall for the garbage math the ekhan
the you what I think is missing from a
lot of these analyses is
the economy can't fully recover
mathematically until the pandemic is
under control what I mean by that is
until people get all their earnings back
they don't have the money to buy stuff
at the rate at which they were
previously that's just math it's simple
math if you don't have as much money as
you did before you can't spend as much
money as you were spending before until
hospitals can do non-emergency
procedures in full the medical
healthcare industry is not going to
recover now I think our industry is a
complete immoral joke the reality is
that it's a huge industry that makes a
lot of money until people are going back
to the doctor the way they were before
for elective and non-emergency
procedures the industry mathematically
cannot recover until dine-in and dine
out restaurants are fully open and safe
restaurants can't recover it's just math
if people aren't going back and the
capacity is diminished the industry
cannot recover
it's just simple arithmetic and we've
not even started to see the fall
semester at colleges and universities
depending on how that goes you could see
massive economic fallout in the 2021
academic year there so do not be tricked
I want things to recover as quickly as
possible but until we actually have the
pandemic under control from a
straight-up math perspective it cannot
happen it simply cannot happen